This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over the years in this job, I've learned a lot of cocktail party facts about the built environment. For example, the tallest building in the world is the Birch Khalifa in Dubai. But the largest building in the world by volume is a Boeing airplane factory in Everett, Washington. It's 472 million cubic feet. The longest bridge is in China, as is the longest wall. No surprise there. But what about the longest fence?
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。多年来，在这份工作中，我学到了很多关于建筑环境的酒会谈资。例如，世界上最高的建筑是迪拜的哈利法塔。但按体积计算，世界上最大的建筑是位于华盛顿州埃弗里特的波音飞机工厂。它有4.72亿立方英尺。最长的桥在中国，最长的墙也在中国。这并不令人惊讶。但最长的围栏呢？
reporter Shirley Wong traveled deep into rural Australia to find it. The longest fence in the world begins just a few hours north of Brisbane on the outskirts of a small town called Gindawi. Jindawi has a hardware store, an accountant's office, a butcher shop, a beauty salon, and a small hotel on top of a pub. Oh, I've got a meat tray raffle. I love those. But I wasn't here to win a meat tray. I came to Jindawi to meet Doug Henning. He's a former tourism officer who agreed to give me a tour of the fence his town is famous for. Hi, so nice to meet you.
记者雪莉·黄深入澳大利亚农村去寻找它。世界上最长的围栏始于布里斯班以北仅几小时路程的一个叫金达威的小镇郊外。金达威有一家五金店、一家会计师事务所、一家肉店、一家美容院，还有一家位于酒吧楼上的小旅馆。哦，我参加了肉类拼盘抽奖。我喜欢那些。但我来这里不是为了赢取肉类拼盘。我来金达威是为了见道格·亨宁。他是一位前旅游官员，他同意带我参观他所在小镇闻名的围栏。嗨，很高兴见到你。
Yeah, thank you. I've been watching the weather. Amazing. The clouds are going that way. So we should be lucky this afternoon. Okay, great. I met up with Doug outside the Jindawi Cultural Center right in the middle of town. And he was standing next to an almost seven foot tall sculpture of a dog.
是的，谢谢。我一直在观察天气。太棒了。云往那边飘。所以我们今天下午应该会很幸运。好的，太棒了。我在镇中心金达威文化中心外见到了道格。他正站在一座近七英尺高的狗雕塑旁边。
It's all made from small pieces of metal, welded together. This metallic hound is a dingo, an animal that can only be found on the island continent of Australia. Dingoes are Australia's apex predator. They are smaller than wolves but can run just as fast. They are lean and extremely athletic. They have reddish blonde fur, white bellies, and pointy ears. They look kind of like, I don't know, buff, Shiba Inus. Given this giant prominent statue, you might think that the people of Gendawi worshipped the mighty dingo.
它完全由焊接在一起的小块金属制成。这只金属猎犬是一只澳洲野犬，一种只能在澳大利亚这个岛屿大陆上找到的动物。澳洲野犬是澳大利亚的顶级掠食者。它们比狼小，但跑得一样快。它们瘦削且极其强壮。它们有红金色的皮毛、白色的腹部和尖尖的耳朵。它们看起来有点像，我不知道，健壮的柴犬。鉴于这座巨大而显眼的雕像，你可能会认为金达威的人民崇拜强大的澳洲野犬。
But Doug informed me this is very much not the case. So there's not a lot of dingo fans in town? Not a great lot. In fact, Jindawi's famous fence was built to keep dingoes out. It's called the dingo barrier fence, and it stretches across the southeastern corner of the continent, separating dingoes from the part of the country where the vast majority of Australians actually live. And it is the longest continuous fence in the world. At over 5,000 kilometers, the dingo barrier fence is longer than the distance between San Francisco and New York City.
但道格告诉我，事实并非如此。所以镇上没有多少澳洲野犬的粉丝？不是很多。事实上，金达威著名的围栏是为了把澳洲野犬挡在外面而建的。它被称为澳洲野犬屏障围栏，横跨大陆的东南角，将澳洲野犬与绝大多数澳大利亚人实际居住的地区隔离开来。它是世界上最长的连续围栏。澳洲野犬屏障围栏全长超过5000公里，比旧金山到纽约市的距离还要长。
And in a field just outside of Gendawi is where the fence starts. That big tree there is the true start of the fence and that goes that way. To be honest, it's not much to look at, just a regular wire fence that's about six feet tall to prevent dingoes from jumping over. I want to stand next to it and see if it goes above my head. I think it should. I'm 5'4. Okay, I'm like about the same height of it. You are standing on a 12-inch mound. I am standing on, okay, fair enough. The fence starts here in the middle of a cattle pasture, and from there it runs all the way across the con.
围栏的起点就在金达威外的一片田野里。那棵大树就是围栏真正的起点，然后往那边延伸。老实说，它看起来没什么特别的，只是一道普通的铁丝网围栏，大约六英尺高，用来防止澳洲野犬跳过去。我想站在它旁边看看它是否比我高。我想应该会。我身高5英尺4英寸。好的，我和它差不多高。你站在一个12英寸的土堆上。我站在，好吧，有道理。围栏从这里开始，位于一个牛牧场的中间，从那里它一直延伸穿过整个大陆。
It just goes on and on and on all the way to South Australia. Yeah, yeah, that's lovely. The dingo barrier fence is a remarkable piece of infrastructure, and not just because of its length. This simple wire structure has actually transformed the entire ecology of Australia. It has split the continent in two, separating animal populations and changing the landscape so much that you can see the effects from space. When you drive around Australia, fences are everywhere. are everywhere. They're used to control the movement of a lot of different kinds of animals. In fact, the dingo fence was originally built to manage a different creature altogether.
它一直延伸，一直延伸，直到南澳大利亚。是的，是的，那太好了。澳洲野犬屏障围栏是一项了不起的基础设施，不仅仅是因为它的长度。这个简单的铁丝网结构实际上改变了澳大利亚的整个生态。它将大陆一分为二，分离了动物种群，并改变了景观，以至于你可以从太空中看到其影响。当你开车环游澳大利亚时，到处都是围栏。到处都是。它们被用来控制许多不同种类动物的活动。事实上，澳洲野犬围栏最初是为了管理另一种完全不同的生物而建造的。
When British colonizers came to Australia in the late 18th century, they wanted this new place to feel like home. And so they took the plants and animals of Europe with them. And a lot of these species were actually brought in, in a lot of cases, for hunting, to allow people to go hunt these animals that they're used to going to hunt in their home country. This is Thomas Newsom, an ecologist and associate professor at the University of Sydney. So foxes, for example, were brought in so people could hunt them. Cats were brought in, they were kept as pets and they established wild populations. But in Australia, we've got other species that were brought in, deer, pigs, goats.
当英国殖民者在18世纪末来到澳大利亚时，他们希望这个新地方感觉像家一样。于是他们带上了欧洲的动植物。在很多情况下，引进这些物种实际上是为了狩猎，让人们能够去猎杀他们在祖国习惯猎杀的动物。这是托马斯·纽瑟姆，悉尼大学的生态学家和副教授。所以，例如，引进狐狸是为了让人狩猎。猫被引进，它们被当作宠物饲养，并建立了野生种群。但在澳大利亚，我们还有其他引进的物种，鹿、猪、山羊。
They were all brought in for some form of a purpose. But that didn't turn out so well. Because of Australia's island geography, the native plants and animals there evolved in relative isolation, which made them particularly vulnerable to invasive species. And without a large number of natural predators, many of these new European creatures ran riot. Unfortunately, all of those, ones I've listed and many more, have created devastating effects on our fauna. The most destructive invader was surprisingly the rabbit.
它们都是为了某种目的而被引进的。但结果并不好。由于澳大利亚的岛屿地理环境，那里的原生动植物在相对隔离的状态下进化，这使它们特别容易受到入侵物种的影响。而且由于缺乏大量的天然捕食者，许多这些新的欧洲生物横行无忌。不幸的是，我列出的所有这些以及更多物种，对我们的动物群造成了破坏性的影响。最具有破坏性的入侵者令人惊讶地是兔子。
Rabbits came to Australia all because of one man, Thomas Austin, whose brother shipped him 24 rabbits from England as a gift. Over the next three years, those 24 animals bred like, well, rabbits. And soon, there were thousands. The rabbits damaged crops, overgrazed grasses, spread diseases, dug holes, wherever they pleased. Basically, they were the worst gift ever and made one man go down in Australian history as the guy who caused the rabbit plague. People tried to hunt them and call them, but there were just too many.
兔子来到澳大利亚全是因为一个人，托马斯·奥斯汀，他的兄弟从英国寄给他24只兔子作为礼物。在接下来的三年里，那24只动物像，嗯，兔子一样繁殖。很快，就有成千上万只了。兔子破坏庄稼，过度放牧草地，传播疾病，随处挖洞。基本上，它们是有史以来最糟糕的礼物，并让一个人作为导致兔子瘟疫的人载入澳大利亚史册。人们试图猎杀和扑杀它们，但数量实在太多了。
And so in 1901, the government created a rabbit department and hired an inspector to study the rabbit population. He found that rabbits hadn't yet crossed into certain agricultural areas, and that gave him an idea. Through years and years of trying to trap these animals, which was unsuccessful, the next step is to try and create a barrier. Rabbits can't climb very easily. They hop, but not particularly high. And so the idea was that they would stop the rabbits with a fence. So rabbit-proof fences were established to try and stop and contain the spread of rabbits throughout Australia. They built three different fences in an effort to seal off a large portion of the continent as a rabbit-free zone. But the rabbits managed to find a way around all of them.
因此，在1901年，政府成立了一个兔子部门，并聘请了一名检查员来研究兔子种群。他发现兔子还没有进入某些农业区，这给了他一个主意。经过多年试图诱捕这些动物的尝试，但没有成功，下一步就是尝试建立一道屏障。兔子不容易爬上去。它们跳跃，但跳得不是特别高。所以想法是他们会用围栏挡住兔子。因此，建立了防兔围栏，试图阻止和控制兔子在澳大利亚的蔓延。他们建造了三道不同的围栏，试图将大陆的一大部分封锁为无兔区。但兔子设法绕过了所有这些围栏。
It wasn't successful. Rabbits ended up going all throughout Australia. Other states built rabbit fences during this period that also failed. And so in the end, the government had all these rabbit fences across the country that were serving no purpose. Over the years, the fences began to disintegrate. But around this time, another European animal was taking over Australia. And soon, all those rusty rabbit fences would be given a new purpose. In the 1800s, wool was a critical material for the British textile industry.
它没有成功。兔子最终遍布了整个澳大利亚。其他州在此期间也建造了防兔围栏，也都失败了。所以最终，政府在全国各地都有这些毫无用处的防兔围栏。多年来，围栏开始解体。但就在这时，另一种欧洲动物正在接管澳大利亚。很快，所有那些生锈的防兔围栏将被赋予新的用途。在19世纪，羊毛是英国纺织工业的关键材料。
But Great Britain didn't have enough land to produce the sheep themselves. So they turned to their colony down under. In 1802, Lord Hobart, who's one of the pooh bars of the British colonial administration, he says, you know, absolutely we want to encourage these colonists to develop fine wool that can suit our manufacturers. That's Trish Fitzsimmons, co-author of the book Fleeced, unraveling the history of wool and war. Trish says that for the first time ever, the reddish landscape of Australia began to be dotted with little white sheep. And over time, the little white dots multiplied.
但英国没有足够的土地来自己生产羊毛。所以他们转向了他们南方的殖民地。1802年，英国殖民政府的头目之一霍巴特勋爵说，你知道，我们绝对希望鼓励这些殖民者开发适合我们制造商的优质羊毛。这是特里希·菲茨西蒙斯，《羊毛与战争的历史》一书的合著者。特里希说，这是有史以来第一次，澳大利亚红色的土地上开始点缀着小白羊。随着时间的推移，小白点越来越多。
By 1880, there were 100 million sheep in Australia, nearly 50 times the number of people. Australian wool was particularly critical for the British military. Wool was the best material for the battlefield because it was waterproof and flame resistant. And by the time World War I rolled around, it was clear that the countries with access to wool had a huge strategic advantage. World War I has got so many more soldiers than any previous war. I want to say 60 or 70 million. Each of those men need something like 20 sheep to support them, keep them alive, keep them warm, just in one year. World War I cemented wool as the foundation of the Australian economy.
到1880年，澳大利亚有1亿只羊，几乎是人口的50倍。澳大利亚羊毛对英国军队尤为关键。羊毛是战场上最好的材料，因为它防水且阻燃。当第一次世界大战来临时，很明显，拥有羊毛资源的国家具有巨大的战略优势。第一次世界大战的士兵比以往任何战争都多。我想说是6000万或7000万。这些士兵中的每一个人都需要大约20只羊来支持他们，让他们活下去，让他们保持温暖，仅仅在一年内。第一次世界大战巩固了羊毛作为澳大利亚经济基础的地位。
But as the industry continued to grow, farmers needed more land for grazing. And so they started to breed sheep that could survive in these super dry marginal regions of the continent. And it was there that the economic superstar of Australia, the sheep, met its great adversary. The dingo. As the wool industry gathers ahead of steam, the areas of the continent, where sheep are grown, starts to expand out into the continent. Those sheep are vulnerable to dingoes. For dingoes, the expansion of sheep into the interior was like a free buffet.
但随着工业的持续增长，农民需要更多的土地来放牧。于是他们开始培育能在大陆这些超级干燥的边缘地区生存的羊。就在那里，澳大利亚的经济巨星——羊，遇到了它伟大的对手。澳洲野犬。随着羊毛工业的发展，大陆上养羊的地区开始向大陆内部扩张。这些羊很容易受到澳洲野犬的攻击。对于澳洲野犬来说，羊群向内部的扩张就像一场免费的自助餐。
But for farmers, the situation was a nightmare. Dingoes are highly effective pack hunters. They are pretty much Australia's version of the big, bad wolf. And farmers would wake up and find that dozens of their sheep had been killed or maimed in dingo attacks. Because of the size of the flocks and their remote locations, it wasn't a simple problem to fix. The whole wool industry itself is set up,
但对于农民来说，情况是一场噩梦。澳洲野犬是高效的群体猎手。它们几乎是澳大利亚版的大灰狼。农民们醒来时会发现，几十只羊在澳洲野犬的袭击中被杀死或致残。由于羊群的规模和它们偏远的地理位置，这不是一个容易解决的问题。整个羊毛工业本身就是这样建立的，
so you can't have predators. It's not financially viable to be out there protecting the sheep. That's Dr. Justine Philip, an environmental historian. We need to be able to put out these flocks of sheep, which number, you know, at least 2,000. You're not talking about a small flock. You're talking 2,000 and upwards, you know, 20,000. 100,000 sheep.
所以你不能有掠食者。在外面保护羊群在经济上是不可行的。这是贾斯汀·菲利普博士，一位环境历史学家。我们需要能够把这些羊群放出去，数量至少有2000只。你说的不是小羊群。你说的是2000只以上，你知道，2万只。10万只羊。
And they basically put them out to pasture and they don't supervise them. So you can't do that without being pretty confident that you've got rid of all the predators in the surrounding area. Farmers wanted to completely eliminate this threat. And because the wool industry was so politically powerful, they got their wish. Australia went to war with the dingo. First, they created incentive programs that encourage farmers to kill dingoes. Soon, there were professional dingo hunters and trappers who were paid bounties for every dingo they killed.
他们基本上把它们放到牧场上，并不监督它们。所以如果不确信你已经消除了周围地区的所有掠食者，你就不能这样做。农民们想彻底消除这种威胁。而且因为羊毛工业在政治上非常强大，他们如愿以偿了。澳大利亚向澳洲野犬宣战。首先，他们制定了激励计划，鼓励农民杀死澳洲野犬。很快，就有专业的澳洲野犬猎人和诱捕者，他们每杀死一只澳洲野犬都会获得赏金。
And then, after World War II, Australia ramped up its assault. A newspaper headline from 1946 read, D-Day for dingoes, above an article describing a plan to drop over 300,000 poisonous dingo baits across the landscape. And so that really brought the whole system up a notch, because instead of having to do ground baiting and doing everything on foot, they actually took the air on these airplanes, which had come back from the war and rent-in-use, and they had lots of pilots that were available for work. And so they started doing enormous aerial baiting projects across Australia.
然后，在第二次世界大战后，澳大利亚加强了攻击。1946年的一条报纸头条写着，“澳洲野犬的D日”，文章描述了一项计划，要在景观中投放超过30万个有毒的澳洲野犬诱饵。所以这确实让整个系统更上一层楼，因为他们不需要进行地面诱饵投放和徒步做所有事情，他们实际上使用了飞机，这些飞机是从战争中回来的，正在使用中，而且他们有很多飞行员可以工作。于是他们开始在澳大利亚各地进行大规模的空中诱饵投放项目。
But at the same time they were slaughtering these animals, the wool industry was developing a different strategy, a plan to keep dingoes and sheep permanently separate. They would take all of those defunct rabbit fences and use them for dingoes instead. And so the rabbit-proof fences were given a dingo renovation. They joined the old rabbit fences together and raised them up to a height that could keep dingoes out. Eventually, they had a big dingo fence, which was once actually 9,600 kilometers long, and it's now still huge, five and a half thousand kilometers long. That's around 3,400 miles, cutting across scrublands and desert.
但与此同时，当他们屠杀这些动物时，羊毛工业正在制定一种不同的策略，一个让澳洲野犬和羊永久分离的计划。他们会拿走所有那些废弃的防兔围栏，转而用于澳洲野犬。于是防兔围栏进行了澳洲野犬改造。他们把旧的防兔围栏连接起来，并把它们加高到可以挡住澳洲野犬的高度。最终，他们有了一个巨大的澳洲野犬围栏，它曾经实际上有9600公里长，现在仍然很大，有5500公里长。大约是3400英里，横跨灌木丛和沙漠。
And though the fence didn't effectively keep out rabbits, it did succeed in its second purpose. Thomas says the fence effectively sealed off nearly a third of the continent as a dingo-free zone. See, we're hitting this point here now, and it goes that way, then, that way, then it goes all the way. Oh, there's some wallabies over there. I see them galloping around. That's the kangaroo. Kangaroo, oh. Yep. I'm back in Jindawi in the eastern state of Queensland,
虽然围栏并没有有效地挡住兔子，但它确实实现了它的第二个目的。托马斯说，围栏有效地将近三分之一的大陆封锁为无澳洲野犬区。看，我们现在到了这个点，它往那边走，然后往那边，然后它一直走。哦，那边有一些小袋鼠。我看到它们在奔跑。那是袋鼠。袋鼠，哦。是的。我又回到了东部昆士兰州的金达威，
and I'm walking along the dingo fence with Doug Henning. Australia still spends big money on this fence, $10 million a year funded through state and local governments and a fence tax on sheep and cattle farmers. The fence is maintained by a team of patrolmen who divvy up the length and each take care of a section. Doug pointed to a hole that had been patched over. See this piece of mesh here?
我正和道格·亨宁沿着澳洲野犬围栏走。澳大利亚仍然在这道围栏上花费巨资，每年1000万美元，由州和地方政府资助，并向养羊和养牛的农民征收围栏税。围栏由一队巡逻员维护，他们分担长度，每人负责一段。道格指着一个被补上的洞。看到这块网了吗？
Yeah. There's a hole underneath there. Okay, I see that, yeah. Something's got through here, so they've come along and put another piece in there. Okay, yeah. What kind of animal would have made that hole? Oh, it'd be very hard to say. I don't know, porcupine.
是的。下面有个洞。好的，我看到了，是的。有东西从这里穿过了，所以他们过来又放了一块补丁。好的，是的。什么样的动物会弄出那个洞？哦，很难说。我不知道，豪猪。
Or echidna? Not a porcupine. That's a different echidna. Sometimes we'll dig a hole like that under a fence. All along the fence, there are a large dents where the wire has been caved in. So what are the dents that we see in the fence? Mainly kangaroos. From running into it?
还是针鼹？不是豪猪。那是另一种针鼹。有时我们会像那样在围栏下挖个洞。沿着围栏，有很多铁丝网凹陷的地方。那么我们看到的围栏上的凹痕是什么？主要是袋鼠。因为撞到它？
They run into it hard enough that it doesn't. They'll did the fence. The animals of the outback damage the dingo fence all the time. But that's nothing compared to the damage the fence does to them. The fence interrupts migration patterns and prevents animals from moving around in search of food or water. Emus, kangaroos, and wallopies all get stuck behind the fence. Some of these creatures play an important ecological role transporting seeds. and so the fence has impacted plant diversity as well.
它们撞得太厉害了，以至于它不会。它们会弄坏围栏。内陆的动物一直损坏澳洲野犬围栏。但这与围栏对它们造成的损害相比根本不算什么。围栏中断了迁徙模式，阻止了动物为了寻找食物或水而四处走动。鸸鹋、袋鼠和小袋鼠都被困在围栏后面。其中一些生物在运输种子方面发挥着重要的生态作用，因此围栏也影响了植物的多样性。
But one of the biggest effects the fence has had on the environment was just removing the dingo from a massive chunk of the continent. As Australia's apex predator, the dingo kept other animal populations in check. And when the dingo went away, it set off a cascade of ecological consequences. The most visible effects are that when dingoes are removed, kangaroos in particular, their numbers explode. That's ecologist Thomas Newsom again. He says that because there are no dingoes eating them,
但围栏对环境产生的最大影响之一仅仅是将澳洲野犬从大陆的一大块区域中移除。作为澳大利亚的顶级掠食者，澳洲野犬控制着其他动物种群。当澳洲野犬消失时，它引发了一连串的生态后果。最明显的影响是，当澳洲野犬被移除时，袋鼠的数量尤其会爆炸式增长。这是生态学家托马斯·纽瑟姆再次说道。他说，因为没有澳洲野犬吃它们，
there are actually too many kangaroos in Australia. I mean, can there really be such a thing as too many kangaroos? Yes, it's gotten to the point where some of my vegan friends who are vegan for ethical reasons will make an exception for kangaroos because hunting them helps control the population. The excess number of kangaroos is a genuine problem in Australia. They end up overgrazing the landscape,
澳大利亚的袋鼠实际上太多了。我的意思是，真的会有袋鼠太多这种事吗？是的，已经到了这种程度，我的一些出于道德原因而吃素的素食主义者朋友会对袋鼠破例，因为猎杀它们有助于控制种群。袋鼠数量过剩在澳大利亚是一个真正的问题。它们最终会过度放牧景观，
taking away the food and shelter that's available for small mammals and birds and reptiles. The population of red foxes and feral cats has also gone up in the absence of dingoes, which in turn has driven native Australian species like bilbies and bandicoots to near extinction. But the impacts of the dingo fence go beyond wildlife. On the dingo side, there are more grasses in leafy ground cover, while on the side without dingoes, there are more dry, woody shrubs. The fence has created essentially two different ecological universes on either side. So there's studies showing that you can see the effects of the dingo fence from space, both in terms of the vegetation that's there on either side, but also they've linked it to changes in dune morphology as well. In the desert on the dingo side of the fence, the land is looser.
夺走小型哺乳动物、鸟类和爬行动物可用的食物和住所。在没有澳洲野犬的情况下，红狐狸和野猫的数量也增加了，这反过来又导致澳大利亚原生物种如兔耳袋狸和袋狸濒临灭绝。但澳洲野犬围栏的影响超出了野生动物。在澳洲野犬的一侧，有更多的草和多叶的地被植物，而在没有澳洲野犬的一侧，有更多的干燥、木质的灌木。围栏实际上在两侧创造了两个不同的生态宇宙。所以有研究表明，你可以从太空中看到澳洲野犬围栏的影响，无论是在两侧的植被方面，而且它们还将此与沙丘形态的变化联系起来。在围栏澳洲野犬一侧的沙漠中，土地更松散，
with dunes that shift in the wind. It's closer to the way the landscape would have looked before colonization. All of this is the ecological price that Australia keeps paying year after year to keep a whole bunch of sheep safe. But the thing is, the wool industry isn't really what it used to be, and sheep are no longer the backbone of the economy. Which makes Australia's commitment to the dingo fence a little hard to understand. What are the conversations around the fence these days?
沙丘在风中移动。它更接近殖民前景观的样子。所有这些都是澳大利亚年复一年为了保护一大群羊而付出的生态代价。但问题是，羊毛工业已经不再是以前的样子了，羊也不再是经济的支柱。这使得澳大利亚对澳洲野犬围栏的承诺有点难以理解。这些天关于围栏的对话是什么？
Like, do people want to tear them down? It's still a hotly debated topic, both among scientists, but also with people who are trying to run sheep or livestock operations in these areas as well. So it would be very difficult, for example, for a politician to come out and say, we're going to tear down the dingo fence. It turns out tearing down the dingo fence is a political third rail. It's not a topic that people would approach normally because it was considered political suicide to talk about removing the dingo fence.
比如，人们想拆掉它们吗？这仍然是一个激烈争论的话题，不仅在科学家中间，而且在这些地区试图经营羊群或牲畜业务的人们中间也是如此。所以，例如，一位政治家出来说我们要拆掉澳洲野犬围栏将是非常困难的。事实证明，拆除澳洲野犬围栏是政治上的禁忌。这不是人们通常会讨论的话题，因为谈论移除澳洲野犬围栏被认为是政治自杀。
Here's Justine Philip again. She says the fence is a symbol of Australia's agricultural heritage. And for politicians who want to show support for farmers, the dingo fence must be upheld. To suggest even that you take it down is considered very un-Australian. I have to admit I was a bit confused hearing Justine say this. I mean, sure, the fence is iconic, unique, totally awesome. Australian. But I kept thinking, so is the dingo. The thing is, the general public hasn't always seen the dingo as this one-of-a-kind
这是贾斯汀·菲利普再次说道。她说围栏是澳大利亚农业遗产的象征。对于那些想要表示支持农民的政治家来说，必须维护澳洲野犬围栏。甚至建议你拆掉它都被认为是非常不澳大利亚的。我必须承认，听到贾斯汀这么说，我有点困惑。我的意思是，当然，围栏是标志性的，独特的，非常棒。澳大利亚的。但我一直想，澳洲野犬也是。问题是，公众并不总是把澳洲野犬看作这种独一无二的
Australian animal like the kangaroo or the koala. In fact, for a long time, people thought dingoes were just regular domestic dogs that had gone wild. Growing up, even Justine believed this. I thought that they would be like a really wild feral dog. I had no idea that they were a separate species. People didn't start to appreciate the dingo until the 1960s when scientists, including Thomas Newsom's dad, Alan, began conducting in-depth research on how unique the dingo truly was.
像袋鼠或考拉那样的澳大利亚动物。事实上，很长一段时间以来，人们认为澳洲野犬只是变野了的普通家犬。在成长过程中，连贾斯汀也相信这一点。我以为它们会像一种非常野的野狗。我根本不知道它们是一个独立的物种。直到20世纪60年代，包括托马斯·纽瑟姆的父亲艾伦在内的科学家开始对澳洲野犬的独特性进行深入研究，人们才开始欣赏澳洲野犬。
They started to understand their movements and behaviors and their diet, and that really formed the basis for understanding their ecological role, but also understanding, well, what are dingoes? because there's also a lot of interest in, well, what are they? Dingoes are a bit hard to classify. Experts say they are descendants of a primitive Asian dog that came to Australia, either with seafarers or by land bridge, somewhere between 4,000 and 10,000 years ago. This has led to some debate about whether or not Dingoes should be considered native to Australia.
他们开始了解它们的活动、行为和饮食，这确实构成了理解它们生态作用的基础，但也理解了，嗯，澳洲野犬是什么？因为人们对它们是什么也很感兴趣。澳洲野犬有点难分类。专家说它们是原始亚洲狗的后代，这些狗在4000到10000年前通过海员或陆桥来到澳大利亚。这导致了一些关于澳洲野犬是否应该被视为澳大利亚本土物种的争论。
But the fact is, Dingoes evolved in Australia, and over centuries, they came to thrive in a range. of habitats all over the continent, from the desert to the tropical rainforest to the Australian Alps. They eventually spent enough time in Australia that they became genetically distinct from their ancestors, meaning the modern dingo has never lived anywhere else. Dingoes were shaped not only by the Australian landscape, but by the people who live there. Before colonization, dingoes had deeply intimate relationships with humans. To the Aboriginal people of Australia, they were partners in hunting and waterfinding.
但事实是，澳洲野犬在澳大利亚进化，几个世纪以来，它们在整个大陆的各种栖息地中茁壮成长，从沙漠到热带雨林再到澳大利亚阿尔卑斯山。它们最终在澳大利亚待了足够长的时间，以至于它们在基因上与它们的祖先不同，这意味着现代澳洲野犬从未在其他任何地方生活过。澳洲野犬不仅被澳大利亚的景观所塑造，还被生活在那里的人们所塑造。在殖民之前，澳洲野犬与人类有着非常亲密的关系。对于澳大利亚的原住民来说，它们是狩猎和寻找水源的伙伴。
Dingoes evolved as a crucial part of Aboriginal life and often resided in their camps, sometimes as protectors or sometimes as companions. Over time, the scientific consensus shifted and people began to understand the Dingo as a native Australian species. And as researchers highlighted the Dingo's origin story, it brought in a whole new generation of Dingo fans like Justine. I did a master's in animal science and then I did my PhD. And a lot of that was around this interest in their misrepresentation, basically. And they were such beautiful creatures. It seemed really strange that they had been greatly misrepresented.
澳洲野犬作为原住民生活的重要组成部分而进化，并经常居住在他们的营地中，有时作为保护者，有时作为同伴。随着时间的推移，科学共识发生了转变，人们开始将澳洲野犬理解为澳大利亚本土物种。随着研究人员强调澳洲野犬的起源故事，它带来了一整代新的澳洲野犬粉丝，比如贾斯汀。我获得了动物科学硕士学位，然后我攻读了博士学位。其中很大一部分是围绕着这种对它们被误解的兴趣。它们是如此美丽的生物。它们被严重误解似乎真的很奇怪。
I also have a lot of sympathy for underappreciated animals, including the dingo. I think it's probably because I watched too much Steve Irwin as a kid on TV. In 1996, Steve visited the... Dingo Fence for an episode of The Crocodile Hunter. We're here in southeast Queensland, and this is the start of the dingo fence. Now, the dingo fence was established in the... Steve drove along the length of the dingo fence, and he was disturbed by what he saw. Hunters and trappers had left dead dingo carcasses everywhere.
我也对未被充分重视的动物有很多同情，包括澳洲野犬。我想这可能是因为我小时候在电视上看了太多史蒂夫·欧文的节目。1996年，史蒂夫访问了……澳洲野犬围栏，拍摄了《鳄鱼猎人》的一集。我们现在在昆士兰东南部，这是澳洲野犬围栏的起点。现在，澳洲野犬围栏建立在……史蒂夫沿着澳洲野犬围栏行驶，他对自己所看到的感到不安。猎人和诱捕者把死去的澳洲野犬尸体到处乱扔。
We find it very difficult to come to terms with seeing dead animals strung up in fences and tree. It's been 30 years. since Steve Irwin recorded that episode. The dingo fence still exists, and people continue to hunt these creatures to keep their populations down. But there is a growing sense in Australia that this is an animal worth protecting.
我们发现很难接受看到死去的动物被挂在围栏和树上。已经30年了。自从史蒂夫·欧文录制那一集以来。澳洲野犬围栏仍然存在，人们继续猎杀这些生物以控制它们的数量。但在澳大利亚，人们越来越感觉到这是一种值得保护的动物。
Coming up after the break, we take you to an island off the coast of Australia where dingoes run free, and where a recent tragedy has people asking whether dingoes and humans can safely coexist. When I finished touring the dingo fence with Doug, I was a little disappointed that apart from the metal sculpture, Doug and I hadn't actually seen a dingo. But there is another place in Australia where anyone who wants to see dingoes is likely to find them.
休息后，我们将带您去澳大利亚海岸外的一个岛屿，那里的澳洲野犬自由奔跑，最近的一场悲剧让人们质疑澳洲野犬和人类是否能安全共存。当我结束与道格参观澳洲野犬围栏时，我有点失望，除了金属雕塑外，道格和我实际上并没有看到澳洲野犬。但在澳大利亚还有另一个地方，任何想看澳洲野犬的人都可能找到它们。
It's an island that was once called Fraser Island, but now goes by its indigenous butchella name, Garry. Garry is covered in tropical rainforest with long white sand beaches and a series of spectacular freshwater lakes. The island is home to a small population of dingoes that have evolved in isolation from the animals on the mainland. When Garry was named a UNESCO World Heritage Site in 1992, the dingoes on the island were officially named an indigenous species and provided legal protection, meaning they are allowed to roam free. The Butchola Aboriginal Corporation hires rangers to deal specifically with dingoes, which they call wongery.
这是一个曾经被称为弗雷泽岛的岛屿，但现在以其原住民布切拉名字“加里”命名。加里覆盖着热带雨林，有长长的白色沙滩和一系列壮观的淡水湖。该岛是少量澳洲野犬的家园，它们在与大陆动物隔离的情况下进化。当加里在1992年被命名为联合国教科文组织世界遗产时，岛上的澳洲野犬被正式命名为本土物种并受到法律保护，这意味着它们可以自由漫游。布切拉原住民公司雇佣护林员专门处理澳洲野犬，他们称之为“旺格里”。
It's a role that Butchilla people have played for Thassau. thousands of years long before colonization. They recognized dingoes as dangerous animals, but ones that were worth keeping around. And they developed non-lethal ways to manage them. For example, if a dingo got too familiar or audacious, they would ward him off with safety sticks. And the tips they give the visitors today are directly informed by the old ways. Like if you're in a camp area, you make sure if you see a wonger even looking or lurking around, you make him know that that's your camp area.
这是布切拉人几千年来，在殖民之前就扮演的角色。他们承认澳洲野犬是危险的动物，但值得保留。他们开发了非致命的方法来管理它们。例如，如果一只澳洲野犬变得太熟悉或太大胆，他们会用安全棍把它们赶走。他们今天给游客的建议直接受到古老方式的启发。比如如果你在营地，如果你看到一只旺格里在周围徘徊，你要让他知道那是你的营地。
Tessa Waya is an officer for the Butchila Aboriginal Corporation, and she works with Park Rangers on Garry. A big part of her job is educating people on how to be safe around dingoes. You know, with a loud voice, shout, yell, he will know, because that's your being the dominant one. And I said, and he will just watch from a fuck, because he knows he's not welcoming there. And that's how that was managed back in the old times to now.
泰莎·瓦亚是布切拉原住民公司的一名官员，她与加里的公园护林员一起工作。她工作的一大部分是教育人们如何在澳洲野犬周围保持安全。你知道，用响亮的声音，大喊，大叫，他会知道，因为那是你作为主导者。我说，他会从远处看着，因为他知道他不受欢迎。这就是过去到现在管理它的方式。
You know what I mean? Tessa told me she believed humans and dingoes can live alongside each other on gari peacefully, just like in the past. But there are real obstacles, including the sheer volume of tourists. Hundreds of thousands of tourists visit gari every year. Many of those people come specifically to catch a glimpse of a dingo. This animal that they've been fed. fenced off from on the mainland.
你知道我的意思吗？泰莎告诉我，她相信人类和澳洲野犬可以像过去一样在加里和平共处。但存在真正的障碍，包括游客的数量。每年有成千上万的游客访问加里。许多人专门来这里看一眼澳洲野犬。这种他们在大陆上被围起来的动物。
And the tour operators use the dingo like a cute mascot to advertise their services. Here's an ad for a tour of the island featuring a strange dingo puppet narrator. Gatay, Darrell the Fraser Island Dingo over here to tell you about the absolute best Fraser Island tag-long tour, your money can buy. Boyd Blackman is a butchilla elder who has worked for 30 years as a ranger in the park. A few years ago, he saw a tour bus with an image of a particularly ridiculous-looking cartoon dingo. The actual dingo was wearing, you know, like a party hat and sunglasses, and he had sneakers on and with a wine shirt, and it said, come party with me. Boyd says that advertisements like this give tourists the wrong impression about these animals.
旅游经营者利用澳洲野犬作为可爱的吉祥物来宣传他们的服务。这是一则岛屿旅游广告，以一个奇怪的澳洲野犬木偶叙述者为特色。嘿，我是弗雷泽岛澳洲野犬达雷尔，在这里告诉你关于你能买到的绝对最好的弗雷泽岛跟团游。博伊德·布莱克曼是一位布切拉长老，他在公园里做了30年的护林员。几年前，他看到一辆旅游巴士，上面有一张特别荒谬的卡通澳洲野犬的图片。真正的澳洲野犬戴着，你知道，像派对帽和太阳镜，他穿着运动鞋，穿着酒红色衬衫，上面写着，来和我一起派对吧。博伊德说，这样的广告让游客对这些动物产生了错误的印象。
Sometimes tourists get too close, or even try to take a selfie with a dingo. You know, for a lot of those backpackers and people that come, I think they might have looked at it as, you know, a lot of people found out that koalas are cute and their cattali until they pull their claws out. The dingo, he's not a party animal. The message, I guess, is, you know, play it safe. These are naturally wild animals.
有时游客靠得太近，甚至试图和澳洲野犬自拍。你知道，对于很多背包客和来这里的人来说，我想他们可能认为，你知道，很多人发现考拉很可爱，直到它们伸出爪子。澳洲野犬，他不是派对动物。我想信息是，你知道，保持安全。这些是天生的野生动物。
Tessa says that the volume of tourists has caused some of gari's dingoes to become habituated to humans. They eat from trash cans and hang around tourists' camps, sites, and that has led to some serious problems. There have been a number of high-profile dingo attacks over the years. You've probably heard about the famous dingo ate my baby case in the 1980s, which happened on the mainland. But there have also been attacks on Gari. In 2001, a young boy was killed by dingoes while camping with his family. After that tragedy, the government
泰莎说，游客的数量导致加里的一些澳洲野犬变得习惯于人类。它们吃垃圾桶里的东西，在游客的营地周围徘徊，这导致了一些严重的问题。多年来发生了一些备受瞩目的澳洲野犬袭击事件。你可能听说过20世纪80年代发生在大陆的著名的“澳洲野犬吃了我的婴儿”案件。但加里也发生过袭击事件。2001年，一个小男孩在和家人露营时被澳洲野犬杀死。那场悲剧之后，政府
culled dingoes and fenced in some of the largest townships on the island to try and keep people safe. But tourism has only increased since then. And while dingo attacks on people are rare, they've been happening more and more in recent years as the island gets more crowded. The Butchila Aboriginal Corporation wants the government to restrict tourism or even close the island altogether during times of the year when dingoes are particularly active. But so far, this has been a non-starter. And then, just as we were getting ready to publish this episode, we begin tonight with a tragedy on Garry. A young Canadian tourist named Piper James was found dead on the beach in Garry.
扑杀了澳洲野犬，并围住了岛上一些最大的城镇，试图保护人们的安全。但从那以后，旅游业只增不减。虽然澳洲野犬对人的袭击很少见，但随着岛上变得越来越拥挤，近年来这种情况发生得越来越多。布切拉原住民公司希望政府限制旅游业，甚至在澳洲野犬特别活跃的季节完全关闭该岛。但到目前为止，这还未开始。然后，就在我们准备发布这一集时，我们今晚以加里的一场悲剧开始。一位名叫派珀·詹姆斯的年轻加拿大游客被发现死在加里的海滩上。
Her body was discovered, surrounded by a pack of dingoes, with significant bite wounds. The exact cause of her death is still unclear. An initial assessment suggests that she drowned, but also that she had been bitten by dingoes before she died. I called Tessa back to see how the community on the island was responding. The community is very shaken up and it's just distressing. Like, you know, I could only imagine what the parents, you know, are going through. And so, yeah, I mean, it's quite heartbreaking.
她的尸体被发现，周围有一群澳洲野犬，有明显的咬伤。她死亡的确切原因尚不清楚。初步评估表明她溺水了，但也表明她在死前被澳洲野犬咬伤了。我打电话给泰莎，看看岛上的社区是如何反应的。社区非常震惊，这令人痛苦。就像，你知道，我只能想象父母，你知道，正在经历什么。所以，是的，我的意思是，这非常令人心碎。
Tessa wouldn't be surprised if Dingoes had been involved in Piper's death. She says the Butchilla Aboriginal Corporation has been saying for years that something like this, might happen. Look, I can't, I was surprised, but wasn't so much a shock in that sense, because we've been actually telling the government that, you know, there needs to be a cap on the visitor numbers. And then they want to say, oh, are we so shocked? Well, no, you were warned. The tragedy on Garri made international news, and it has sparked a lot of fierce debates about how to respond. In the end, the government made the decision to euthanise the pack of 10 dingoes that had been found near the body, arguing it was necessary for public safety.
如果澳洲野犬卷入了派珀的死亡，泰莎不会感到惊讶。她说布切拉原住民公司多年来一直说，这样的事情可能会发生。看，我不能，我很惊讶，但并没有那么震惊，因为我们实际上一直在告诉政府，你知道，游客数量需要有一个上限。然后他们想说，哦，我们太震惊了？好吧，不，你被警告过了。加里的悲剧上了国际新闻，并引发了关于如何应对的激烈辩论。最终，政府决定安乐死在尸体附近发现的10只澳洲野犬，理由是公共安全所必需。
But several scientists have questioned that decision, arguing that previous dingo calls have not made the island safer. There are somewhere between 70 and 200 dingoes left on Garay, and scientists argue that killing any of these animals reduces critical genetic diversity and makes the population much more vulnerable to extinction. The Butchila Aboriginal Corporation says they were not consulted about the decision to called the dingos. And when Tessa found out that the animals had been killed,
但几位科学家质疑这一决定，认为以前的澳洲野犬扑杀并没有让岛屿更安全。加里还剩下70到200只澳洲野犬，科学家认为杀死这些动物中的任何一只都会减少关键的遗传多样性，并使种群更容易灭绝。布切拉原住民公司表示，他们没有就扑杀澳洲野犬的决定进行咨询。当泰莎发现这些动物被杀死时，
she was devastated. So when we had found out, it was very sad. Everyone was sad. You know, because to the butchal of people, the wongarees are their family, you know, is like their brothers, their sisters. You know, like, so that's, you know,
她崩溃了。所以当我们发现时，非常难过。每个人都很伤心。你知道，因为对布切拉人来说，旺格里是他们的家人，你知道，就像他们的兄弟，他们的姐妹。你知道，所以这就是，你知道，
how significant these animals are to them. These wongis, they're punished for doing what they do naturally. It's not right. Dingoes have a fraught history in Australia. They are an iconic, charismatic animal, but they are also dangerous predators, and have often been treated as a problem or a pest. Dingoes have been fenced out and killed off to make way for human activity. The Aboriginal history in a place like Gari shows that humans and dingoes can coexist, but coexistence in the modern world will require a complicated rebalancing of the relationship.
这些动物对他们有多重要。这些旺格里，因为做它们自然做的事情而受到惩罚。这不对。澳洲野犬在澳大利亚有着令人担忧的历史。它们是一种标志性的、有魅力的动物，但它们也是危险的掠食者，经常被视为问题或害虫。澳洲野犬被围起来并被杀光，为人类活动让路。像加里这样的地方的原住民历史表明，人类和澳洲野犬可以共存，但现代世界的共存将需要对这种关系进行复杂的重新平衡。
This is a difficult but necessary challenge because these are beautiful creatures and Australia is their only home. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Shirley Wong produced and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald with help from Kelly Prime mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swanreale and George Langford. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Special thanks to David Murkumthura,
这是一个困难但必要的挑战，因为它们是美丽的生物，而澳大利亚是它们唯一的家。本周的《99%隐形》由雪莉·黄报道，由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作和编辑，凯利·普莱姆协助，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安完成。特别感谢大卫·默库姆图拉，
Madeline Shaw, co-author of the book Fleeced and Ronald Breckwald, author of the book Dingo. the true story of Australia's most maligned native animal. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon,
马德琳·肖，《羊毛》一书的合著者，以及罗纳德·布雷克沃尔德，《澳洲野犬：澳大利亚最被诋毁的本土动物的真实故事》一书的作者。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、
Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉舍马顿、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。
in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有该链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。